hi guys my name is a Alto Belson
and today I'm gonna speak about how you
can get to know any deficit in four
lines of Punto so let's imagine a
scenario you and a data set walk into a
bar
so we have our account table and you
really want to understand what it
contains
so the most probable strategy that you
will take is to just clearly a lot of
questions like how the revenue column is
distributed what is the minimum and
maximum values how many missing values
do we have and do the same for size and
country but that's just not the proper
way to do it so what's one it's time
consuming it's certainly not fun it's a
Volpone and some of the questions may
require a lot of skills like if you want
to say what's the correlation of size
and revenue so there must be a better
way and the with we're gonna utilize
pandas and it's amazing gecko system to
automate the post the process as much as
possible so this is an amazing
reliability that automate 90% of this
work
it's called pandas waffling and it
creates an HTML report of all the
question that you might have on a data
set so what's this snippet we start with
a data set whether it's a file CSV a
table we then read it to a panda's data
frame whether with read CSV or with
sequel depending on your time and then
the one-liner the tuple the magic is
pandas waffling dot profile report this
generate HTML that give us all the
answers if you want to render it in
Jupiter you just keep it as if and if
you want to create an HTML file you
write to file so I will show
an animation of the previous and what
generated for the previous slide so in
the top right you can see table of
content and I will start going Google it
so we have an overview of our data set
and I remind you it's automatic so we
have the number of valuables we have 13
columns we have 800 rows we have
statistic on missing values duplicate
and the size and how the variable types
are distributed so this dataset is the
Pokemon dataset phone column so it's a
bit cleaner than you would expect most
of the dataset so the first thing that
you will see is warnings like the second
morning is that the type 2 of the
Pokemon has a lot of missing values and
this is the most crucial palette each
will get a lot of statistics how many
distinct count how many missing values
in placenta average minimum maximum how
many zeroes if you toggle for details
you can get the most common values and
extreme values in histogram quantum
statistics and descriptive statistics of
course if it's category available we get
different type of metrics specifically
here we don't have a lot of categorical
one next we have the correlation part
which requires a lot of skills many
people will probably just skip it so we
have different type of correlations for
example you can see here that the number
of the pokemon i'll correlate with the
generation it become it belongs to you
can see in the red stone dead illah
so there is another section here but I
won't go over it because I don't have
time which is correlation of missing
values and the two more level is that I
want to show you there are less crucial
but they can be useful there is pivot
table GS which allows you to create
interactive pivot tables to slice your
dataset and see the distribution and
aggregation so this is again the snippet
only additional line and yet again we
start with a data set we did a panda's
data frame and create an HTML so if we
can see any animation of how the
accountable is distributed here of the
real across different industries you can
choose how to visualize it whether as a
bitmap always a bottom and it can be
really time-saver
instead of like writing it on your own
the last thing that I want to show you
is Phi D QC this library allows you to
compare two data sets so a useful
example is when you want to compare a
distribution of the training set and the
test set so again we start with data set
will lead them to memory and then we
plot the data set they image so we can
see in the right an example for for a
numerical one we have the plot that
compels them we have minimum of both we
have median we have mean in for example
it's a data set that just copied the
same the same data but on different time
and on the left you can see the time
itself so we are the maximum and the
minimum and the plot itself so there is
no silver bullet
because pandas shine on non nested data
set so you might need to write more
four lines of fight one if you have
NSTIC JSON for example also pandas
requires a lot of one because you load
it in memory so for most use cases it
will be enough to just sample the data
set but there are more tweaks that you
can do on the type itself and the last
thing there are some question that may
arise that you will need to just write
code to answer them like if you want to
see outliers across different columns
and that's it
[Applause]